From your unproblematic fave, Tina Fey,
from your slightly problematic fave, Tina Fey.
A hundred years from now, people will see my work and think, wow,
that is actually pretty racist.
Comes a ruthless tale of pointless cruelty, full of miserable teenagers,
trapped in a Hill of their own creation.
Basically the most honest high school movie ever made mean girls
move over breakfast club so long clueless. And who said,
you could sit with us Netflix girls because it's time for one of the best high
school movies of the early two thousands. In fact,
one of the best things from the early two thousands,
but that really isn't saying much. Let's just get the nostalgia for that decade.
Okay. Trust us bet. Before Lohan was making reality shows,
pop albums and court appearances.
And before Rachel McAdams was getting some strange, they were in mean girls,
the funniest comedy to ever be adapted from a non-fiction parenting advice book
in this hilarious satire that could either be viewed as a plea for teen girls to
be more kind to each other or an instruction manual for future sociopaths.
It could really use an update though.
Like how do I destroy the thought of does my junk coupon cam please advise
welcome to one of the most racially segregated high schools in Illinois.
The nerds cool Asians, unfriendly black hotties.
Where the popular girls are cruel. God, Karen you're so stupid.
The unpopular girls are vengeful and manipulative.
And you're best friends against her.
And we gave you a foot cream instead of face washes.
The teachers are statutory rapists and the bus drivers really want
to get kids to school on time.
Shove it right up your hair.
Tossed into this jungle is Katie she's from Africa.
I just moved here from Africa, which country, you know,
Africa shut up.
She doesn't know about basic things like fashion cliques or African-Americans
jumbo because she was homeschooled by the parents from get out.
The fertility files I put in the belly tribe.
I would have voted for Obama for a third term.
Watch Katie enlist, the help of her gay best friend and her friend.
Who's mortified. People wouldn't even think she's gay.
I feel like you're like in love with me or something.
Not to infiltrate the popular clique known as the plastics, uh,
group of Abercrombie and is led by Regina,
George who so mean you'll barely care. When the hero Stoker eating disorder.
I'm only eating foods with less than 30% calories from fat.
I really want to lose three pounds.
Let's go the South beach fat flush and all you drink is cranberry juice for 72
hours.
Karen Smith, the second dumbest weather reporter from a 2004 film.
Said 30% shifted, sorry,
rating and 38 degrees in the middle.
And Gretchen wieners who ironically,
isn't the girl who made out with a hot made out.
With a hot dog. Oh my God. That was one time.
Together.
These Von duchesses will ruthlessly scheme to stay popular in a
fiendish plot to, uh, that's pretty much it,
but they wrote some mean stuff in a private journal years ago.
So monsters follow along on Katie's uncomfortably,
true to life evolution from wholesome silver kid to out of control party girl,
as she steals a guy so nice.
He dated Regina twice gets a teacher arrested. I.
Bet she sells drugs on the side to be for pathetic divorce.
And incites a riot,
but it's nothing a single apology and an afternoon of trust balls. Can't pigs.
See now everyone is friends with everyone. Oh, it's still full quicks.
Just the members changed. Well,
at least they can kill the ones who get too powerful.
So revisit one of the most quotable movies of all time.
Cool. Stop trying to make fetch happen. It's not going to happen.
You'll go Glenn.
Call that leans on the strings of great future stars and just the right amount
of SNL people to anchor a field with a wise and lasting message.
Math is for losers.
No, no, no. Mathletes. I pretended to be bad at maths that you'd help me.
I didn't join those stupid math leaks. I'm a math leap.
A nerd is birth detention, mathletes it's social suicide. Thanks Damien.
Starring Katie bird Regina,
the teenage quiz Limon director of education.
Steven Booth wet hot American mother fetch happens.
Amanda hug and kiss. Lizzie cap would be gay Powell,
river dough.
You plus me equals us and YouTube comments, correct?
Fat version white chicks.
Don Schweitzer has a huge who would write that?
Cardi B Megan, the stallion just spit balling here.
I'm Mike Tyson and I approve this message.
Do the oysters come with guns?
I like my eggs crunchy.
His kids still thrills me after a millennia.
If loving me is wrong, you don't want to be right.